[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages time then to see
what's making the headlines with the
observer's chief leader writer Sonia
soda and the director of communications
at The Institute of economic Affairs
Annabelle Denham welcome to both of you
with us from now until just before
midnight so to the front pages let's
start with the guardian it leads with
tomorrow's strikes across a wide variety
of sectors with teachers rail staff
civil servants and others taking part
The Daily Mail also leading with strikes
calling the teachers walkout cynical
according to the eye conservative back
benches are continuing to put pressure
on the chancellor Jeremy Hunt to cut
taxes the express reports on a 16.7
year-on-year increase in food prices
the Metro has word of a contentious
exchange between the breakfast TV host
Kate garraway and the former Health
secretary Matt Hancock over his
appearance on I'm a celebrity caraway's
husband was left with severe
disabilities after falling ill with
covid the sun covers The Disappearance
of mother of two Nicola bully in
Lancashire
the financial times here's that member
states have told senior EU officials not
to over promise when it comes to the
possibility of Ukraine joining the
organization
and the star says there's been a bit of
a misunderstanding at Twitter after
representatives of a bird charity in
Norfolk were apparently banned for
mentioning woodcocks
well it reminded that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers Wally
Watcher so let's head to Sonia and to
Annabelle
um so a bit of a complication of strikes
that IMF report tax cut demands
um
Etc
um first of all let's kick off with the
strikes Then Shall We The Guardian Sonia
half a million to strike and unions
walking the warning that talks are going
backwards I suppose most notably we get
the teachers walking out in England and
Wales don't we
yes so this is hugely significant for
parents in England and Wales it's a
first national strike for a number of
years in England and Wales the National
Education Union whose teachers are
striking whose members are striking uh
say that it could be up to 200 000
teachers on strike we don't know the
exact numbers because teachers aren't
obliged to notify schools until the
morning of the strike and they think
that it could affect up to 85 of schools
in England and Wales we've obviously
already seen some teacher strikes um in
Scotland
um I I think if you look at
um public polling on the strikes
sympathy for teachers is pretty high not
quite as high as for nurses and
ambulance workers but there is a lot of
sympathy there and I think that's
because people know that when you look
at teacher pay the settlement that's on
offer from the government this year is
below inflation
um it's sort of in the in the ballpark
of between five and six percent when at
Point this year inflation has been above
10 percent so that's a real pay cut for
teachers if you look at senior teaching
staff their real pay has fallen quite
significantly over the last decade so
they're going on strike for very similar
reasons to the nurses I think which is
partly about levels of real pay the fact
that it's not keeping Pace with what's
going on the private sector at the
moment and with the cost of living
crisis that makes it very difficult
particularly for teachers um you know at
the lower end of pay scales to get by
but also because there is a real concern
about the impact of levels of real pay
on Recruitment and Retention within the
teaching profession and there are a
number of subjects in secondary schools
for example where there is a real
shortage of teacher that teaches that
has huge knock-on impacts for the long
term on children's education but huge
disruption for parents as you can
imagine yes I suppose two questions from
that Annabelle
um one would public servants always
anticipate pay would match inflation and
secondly the impact on the economy after
the IMF report about growth certainly
the Metro suggesting that strikes are
set to close schools universities
transport networks and disrupt
public sector Services I mean that is
growth damaging isn't it
sure I think you know to your first
point that we need to remind ourselves
that the mean salary for a teacher in
2021 was nearly 42 and a half thousand
pounds now this might not be as good as
many teachers
um would like or indeed as much as it
perhaps has been in the past and I think
a lot of members of the public will have
a sympathy with their position but
nonetheless it is very good compared to
the national average salary of 32
000 pounds and of course that's before
you add pension contributions of nearly
24 which is worth roughly another ten
thousand pounds on average and I think
and often a neglected element of this
debate is just how high public sector
pensions are compared to those working
even in the private sector even if
private sector wage growth is growing
more quickly um in terms of the
disruption that we're facing across the
economy yes it could potentially cost
hundreds of billions of pounds and I
think we could see public support for
teachers begin to wane when parents are
forced to take time off potentially
losing their own pay but I think we need
to put this in some context we are not
in the 1970s at least not in my view
most of these strikes cannot seriously
damage the public they're not like
miners for instance who in the past
stayed up for months and led to power
cuts and three day weeks we saw terrible
images of the unburied Dead you know we
are just simply not in that situation
now and that's partly because uh thanks
to lockdown we've adapted to working
from home so many workers will be
impacted less we don't rely on Legacy
institutions like raw mail as much as we
used to
um nonetheless they will be disruptive
and I think the the trouble is that
while we may have a lot of sympathy with
those going on strike the country has
taken a big hit to GDP uh compared to
where we would be uh had it not been for
covid and the Ukraine a new channel has
been blown in the public finances living
standards have necessarily Fallen a bit
and not all people can expect to be
compensated so you could you can see the
government's position as well
um and maybe public sympathy will indeed
start to to wane but it's not as though
the government is is very popular at the
moment so economically damaging um then
Sonia politically damaging uh possibly
two
um certainly with an election
um you know in the offing next year
Rachel Reeves a shadow Chancellor with a
foretelling of one strategy if you like
for labor suggesting voters should ask
themselves am I better off than in 2010
when the conservatives came in and the
Metro citing a trades Union Congress
report published today
um saying the average public sector
worker is now 203 pounds per month worse
off than in 2010. now if that's true
then the answer to Rachel Reed's
question would be no
foreign
that's right and actually if you look at
private sector pay as well the drop
isn't as big as for public sector pay
but there is a drop in private sector we
alternate pay as well this has been an
extraordinary decade of lost pay growth
and I think it's a product of a number
of things it's a product of you know
Britain's very slow productivity growth
since a financial crisis I think it's
partly a product of brexit which is
really harm productivity it's had a big
impact on exporters and their ability to
export to our biggest neighbor and it's
also a product of the government's
failing to address the reasons for
Britain's slow productivity growth
failing to address the reasons for slow
growth and I think we've had a
government that has created a lot of
rhetoric around growth around leveling
up but actually when you look at it the
policies just aren't there in terms of
the investment you need to get growth
into all areas of the country so it's
really grim and you know we're gonna
we're about to look forward I think the
IMF forecast you know I am at the IMF
producer's latest forecast today Britain
is the only country the only developed
oh we've lost you momentarily Annabelle
pick up on that if you can this idea of
the government addressing slow growth
certainly something it was something Liz
trust was very keen on and you were
somewhat keen on her too in your
organization but do you do we focus on
the big issues such as the financial
crisis and the years of austerity on
brexit on the pandemic on the war in
Ukraine or the minutiae of how the
economy Works in this country for
example
um the vat rate when it kicks in for
small Traders a massive drop-off for
them many of them tried to choose to
work not past that cut off at whatever
it is 80 000. you know do we need to
look at every part of our economy to try
to bring in growth do you think
uh yes absolutely I think the economy is
in pretty poor shape and there are a lot
of issues
um which need to be addressed I think
Liz truss made many missteps but one
thing she did get right was putting
growth back on the agenda this is
absolutely essential as I think Sonia
was underscoring then we need to tackle
uh why it is that we've had years of
anemic growth word is that we've had
years of low productivity I would argue
that we urgently need a supply side
reforms across ways of our economy we
need to liberalize planning to make it
easier to build homes make it easier for
people to move and to move where the
jobs are and where the jobs are that
they can be most productive we need to
deregulate areas like the labor market
which piles on costs to employers and
disincentivizes uh employment we need to
deregulate child care which has led to
us having among the highest
out-of-pocket child care costs for
parents of anywhere in the oecd that
there are so many areas of the econ to
me that need to be addressed on the
supply side up front as well as just
this incessant growth that we've seen in
recent years of government and therefore
government spending which has to be
funded somewhere
um and it has led to higher taxes which
again can disincentivize people from
working or from from working for longer
so I think that there's so many problems
while there are economy and I'm not
altogether convinced that Rishi sunak
and Jeremy Hunt are really committed to
addressing them and it's not really all
that surprising that Jeremy Hunt and
wish you would see now are facing some
Rebellion from uh some Tory members in
response to this because I think a lot
of Voters are asking themselves what the
difference now is between labor and the
conservatives labor are repeatedly
parking tanks on the Tories lawn they
are trying to establish themselves as
the party of business
um the Tories can hardly claim to be the
party of low taxes when they're
presiding over the highest tax burden in
over 70 years the situation for the
conservative party is is not looking
good but more importantly it's not
looking good for the average ordinary
man and woman in Britain today and I
struggle to see how things are going to
improve at any point really in this year
yes I suppose the problem for Liz truss
was she wanted tax cuts alongside
massive expenditure in energy support
using borrowing to bridge the gap at a
time of high inflation the combination
of which was not popular as we all know
with the markets Rishi sunak and Jeremy
Hunt making quite clear that inflation
is their number one priority Mr Hunt
obviously addressing the 1922 committee
today and it is inflation on the front
page of the Daily Express are still
staggering to use their word 16.7 rise
still uh Sonia in food prices
yeah that's right um which I think
people will look at and feel really
worried about
um this would be the highest level of
food inflation since records began
according to the express and food is
obviously a smaller part of household
budgets than energy costs and housing
costs but it's still a significant cost
and we know that too many families are
struggling to put food on the table
um I would just come back on some of the
points that Annabelle was making that
won't come as any surprise to your
viewers I think Annabelle works for um a
think tank that's on the right I'm a
commentator on a center-left newspaper
so we have very different views about
the policy prescriptions that are needed
to inject growth into the economy for me
it's absolutely not about eroding
workers rights so things like holiday
pay and maternity rights
um that's not what's going to lead to
growth and actually if you look at the
evidence the macro evidence on tax cuts
I don't think there's any good
International macro evidence at cutting
taxes how has been linked with periods
of growth in the past and in fact if you
look at many European countries that
have much better growth prospects
according to the IMF
um in the uh coming year they have
higher state spending as a proportion of
GDP than we do so these are political
choices they are not mutually exclusive
with um high growth they're about the
kind of society you want to live in but
what I would say is that personally I
think the last 12 years of cutting back
in public spending you know key bits of
Public Service infrastructure transport
infrastructure there's a huge gap in the
spending for example and transport
infrastructure when you compare the
North and the South that all impacts on
growth in other parts of the country and
it's why the UK has got some of the
biggest Regional variations in
prosperity and growth of any developed
country well certainly the conservative
party can't agree either if you look at
the front page of the eye as I said
Jeremy Hunt meeting some of those
members of the of the 1922 committee the
back benches of the Tory party angrily
confronting him over his refusal to cut
taxes you know why cut them why cut them
now why not just let inflation do its
thing and try to get reduced Annabelle
why why is this still the priority for
some conservatives
I think for uh some conservatives
cutting inflation just won't cut the
mustard let's not forget that inflation
is scheduled or expected to come down at
some point in 2023 and continue to do so
in 2024 so Richie's doing that with
those those pillars particularly on
inflation really was just uh promising
uh something that was probably going to
happen anyway which just probably wasn't
enough for some conservative about
Adventures the point is where where does
the money come from for tax cuts right
now is the point I suppose I'm making
sure well I would like to see the
government Reign and uh of raining
Raining spending and I don't think it's
really obvious that you can point to one
area of government spending that you
could uh immediately cut and it would
lead to Prosperity although I'd like to
see even now hs2 uh be thrown on the
scrap Heap but what we really need the
government to do is go through every
area of government spending and identify
waste identify areas that that could be
uh cut and put that towards lowering
taxes
um which you know as I say the
government has has really failed to do
despite being as allegedly conservative
government we really are moving towards
having a Social Democrat government of
the kind that Sonia was
um praising uh that we see in countries
like
um Scandinavia and I do think it's
actually possible that the the
forthcoming budget in March might see uh
Jeremy Hunt pledge to cut taxes or
perhaps continue with the freeze in fuel
Duty and he's choosing this moment to
keep his cards close to his chest but I
could be wrong he may be waiting until
right before the 2024 general election
okay we're uh we're running over it's a
fascinating debate which is happening in
all walks of society right now isn't it
not least with the Striking workers who
want more pay I guess too
um anyway lots more stuff to come in the
next part of our program uh police
apologize to the families of
Hillsborough victims and pledged to be
more open in future
[Music]
thank you
you're watching the Press preview with
me once again Sonia soda and Annabelle
Denham welcome back to both of you
um so let's go to the guardian shall we
and uh at last some might say an
official apology has been issued for the
police failures that led to the unlawful
killing of 97 people in the Hillsborough
disaster and with that comes a promise
from police forces Across the Nation uh
to offer openness and Candor I mean you
know Sonia 34 years it's taken to get
this far
yeah 34 years um in the making
um and this is the official national
police response the 2017 report that was
produced by the former Archbishop of
Liverpool he'd also done obviously the
landmark 2012 report that exposed um the
South Yorkshire police negligence that
um led to the deaths of of 97 innocent
um Liverpool fans
um and so this is the official police
response five years later
um it's the official apology it comes
jointly from the National Police Chiefs
councils and the College of policing
they've made a number of undertakings in
a 56-page report to do things
differently going forwards I think some
might say well why did it take five
years to come back on this but there
were also questions for the government
because the 2017 report made a number of
recommendations about changes to the law
um a group of changes to the law that
include for example things like a duty
of Canada on police that the government
is yet to respond to now the Home
Secretary says well that's because we
can't Prejudice any uh trials that are
ongoing but I mean there hasn't even
been a government response let alone
attempts to legislate so I think you
know the bereaved families of hillbrow
Hillsborough and people who were injured
um in Hillsborough really have very
legitimate questions to ask about why
it's just taking so long
yes that's the top of the Sun as well um
cops admit we've failed families cops
finally apologized they said for failing
families over that disaster in 1989 but
let's move on to the Metro
um Matt Hancock being taken to task by
Kate garraway over his appearance on I'm
a celebrity and there's questions of
course about the handling of kovid
Annabelle
well yes I mean and this was to be uh
expected uh that Matthew Hancock thought
he could go on I'm a celebrity and that
would be some form of atonement I always
thought was for the birds and I I'm
pleased to see that he's continued to
get scrutiny not just of his handling of
the coronavirus pandemic but also his
decision to go on reality television uh
when he was supposed to be representing
his uh constituents uh in Suffolk but
yes it's immensely difficult of course
um for Kate uh Gary given her husband uh
Derek Draper spent months in an induced
coma after Contracting coronavirus he
continues to suffer from uh long covid
there were periods of course when she
wouldn't have been able to see him in
hospital just like many families who
were separated from their loved ones and
yet the man who was Health secretary at
the time who was helping set the rules
was behind the scenes uh not obeying
them himself so you know still I feel as
though there's quite a lot of public
anger towards uh Matt Hancock he's
failed to absolve himself apologies for
butting in there Annabelle Sonia thank
you both very much indeed thank you